vous avez lu les bouquins de virgine
despentes vos j'ai lu j'ai lu les jolies
choses enfin j'ai lu surtout
d'adaptations cinématographiques qui en
est peut-être en est faite
voilà maintenant je vous dis une
question quand on est libéral est ce qu
on est libéral au niveau du sexe aussi
vous menez le genre de vie que vous
voulez ça ne regarde pas avancer bien
simplement où il n'empêche pas d'avoir
chacun une petite boussole de valeur à
savoir comment on se comporte
pour cela ce contenu estime bien ce
qu'on estime mal mais vous faites la vie
vous voulez la double peine et pour le
libéro si je devine que le libre échange
vous émoustille et pendant ce temps là
jean claude brialy ça va vous faites vos
affaires j'aimerais bien vous assister
en direct à un événement extraordinaire
ces gens qui utilisent alors non je
trouve que c'est magnifique d'entendre
les jeunes femmes qui ont une sincérité
ne et on sent aussi dans le regard
quelques jours douloureux je trouve ces
mots non mais bon c'est le champagne a
donné 15 jours magnifiques souvent les
gens viennent vendre leurs affaires
ouais et tout eh bien écoutez bien et là
on sent qu'elle sincérité sur le fait
que sa marque est la chose la plus belle
qui soit dans le décor le dernière
question pardon patrick dans l'art c'est
d'assumer way virginie venez tous avec
les mecs là parce que quand je vous ai
connu
alors quand je les ai connus de paris
dernière en 95 vous me disiez ni garçon
n'y fit je rentre chez moi
pichard je fais du sport je vais faire
il faut faire du sport faut courir pour
évacuer tout ça c'était un peu la
chasteté un peu triste oui quoi non bah
c'est resté un peu pareil merde du
boulot avec les mecs parce que vous
dites j'ai un problème non pas avec les
mecs j'ai un problème avec tout ce qui
est dominant bon mais si vous trouviez
un mec qu'ils soient pas dominant
n'hésite pas à prendre avec les maxi
tels que ça ça va pas avec ce que
dominant on va par contre j'ai déjà plus
un problème à dominante
je préfère qu'on foute la paix sur
toutes ses stars et moi aussi
à vous aussi la patience est contagieux
son affaire nous sortîmes rien mais
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
dicter sa loi 104 bien de soutenir saab
à quoi est ce que tu veux qu'on soit
soumis aux dominants ou ce que tu veux
soumis tous mis d'accord je vais changer
un peu je serai ton chien
ok pas de problème ok voilà bien un bel
sa lumière ne bouge pas pendant le
jingle au brésil
[Musique]
une balle
alors je vous faire virginie et chorales
et une petite interview psy c'est tombé
sur vous voulez pas répondre coralie on
va voir en face en virginie sinon comme
avec edouard baer cebrian y avait pour
moi ah bah si si si alors est ce qu est
ce que vous êtes parano les filles moi
un peu ouais enfin bon il faut qu'il
faut pour être par le paraguay est ce
que vous êtes schizo ouais mon pas
tellement non bah non apparemment non
puisque il n'y a pas de différence entre
votre vie professionnelle et votre vie
privée vous dites que ça fait partie de
moi j'ai beaucoup de facettes
différentes facettes sans aucun problème
très bien qu est ce que vous êtes sado
vaguement quand même vous aimez bien
faire mal ouais j'aime bien les masos
répondants sont pas trop mais par contre
ça dos j'ai pratiqué pendant que je vais
beaucoup plus jeune vous avez fait la
dominatrice
ouais et alors alors c'était rigolo mais
on s'en lasse ah oui on s'en lasse aussi
alors
[Musique]
c'est non seulement vous êtes exhibo oui
vous chorale et on le sait vous l'avez
dit allez votre époque gothique en vous
et l'amour sur la scène de la loco
virginie est ce que vous êtes exhibo non
non vous êtes géronto pourquoi pas j'ai
honte aux noirs et gérante au noir
manteau
voilà est-ce que vous êtes pédo plus
j'aime plus les garçons que les hommes
en fait voilà donc c'est un peu pédo je
reconnais
aussi si presse est ce que cette zone
voilà non non jamais jamais si des beaux
arts est ce que vous êtes
ayrault c'est quoi ouais pourquoi pas
ouais je vous ai de coco arrive
moi j'ai tout essayé sauf l'hérault en
fait vous êtes coco
vous êtes adamo non je suis allé
remercier la pire de toutes c'est habib
est en berne et vous n'êtes pas d'amour
c'est vrai m tombe la neige annonce qu
est ce que vous êtes disco venir ou pas
d'emploi spécifiquement si j'ai beaucoup
bu pourquoi pas
[Musique]
jackal virginie despentes
je suis
pandémie
le morceau de corde coban illustrait le
titre de votre livre virginie qui
s'appelle teen spirit c'est votre
quatrième roman est voulue publié chez
grasset ça va voyager une bonne tête ça
ça va ouais c'est pas le temps bonne
compagnie nous avait un chapeau merci
donc la bonne surprise
virginie c'est que vous ne vous êtes pas
laissé prendre au piège de votre propre
image en est loin du trash et duhart
sexe de vos romans précédents c'est pas
ben moi non non le buzz moi je les ai
déjà fait à mon avis je les réussis
ouais non non je suis autre chose puis
avec ça aurait été bête de ma part de
prêter les flancs parce qu'à mon avis on
m'attend au tournant donc fallu créer un
bouquin voilà on vous attendait pas il
ya un truc chez le narrateur qui
arrivent pas éjaculer bon pas bon il y
aura six du tantrisme un fait du web et
puis j'arrive à des gens très bien
et puis le may cry d'enculés la gonzesse
pour faire pour ça dit - virginie vous
êtes embourgeoisé ou non par rapport à
l'époque des besoins avaient la même vie
que j'ai l'impression d'avoir été
récupérés par des systèmes non non ont
vu la sortie du film ça va à la première
mention je suis tranquille mais c'est
clair ce n'est pas nous faire un bébé
quand même non non j'ai pas que ça à
faire assez optimiste pour faire un bébé
pas assez optimiste non pas assez
optimiste puis c'est pas c'est tout ce
que j'ai vécu ces dix années à venir y
la vie sur la terre va être encore pire
avec qui viennent ouais t'es fier à des
trucs rigolos en fait c'est ce qu'on va
rarement des à mettre des trucs marrants
quoi mais je crois plutôt que ça va être
catastrophique
à la voir il ya des gens je me dire ah
non c'est ce qu'on a fait un grand
bordel ça va être marrant mais la
plupart du temps je me dis plutôt un
moment donné on va vraiment avoir un
régime totalitaire fort et ça va être
rigolo du tout pensé ça c'est ce qui
c'est ce que j'imagine moi vous avez du
mal à vous remettre à l'écriture
heureusement les mensualités que vous
verse les éditions grasset vous y ont
obligé c'est pas mal finalement
ouais sinon je me serais pas remis à
l'écriture après le truc du film ouais
non c'est clair vallon c'est bien mais
tu as on serait pas payé je serais rien
du tout un genre pas besoin de gagner
des sous alors j'ai attendu plus d'un an
avant de commencer vous avez pris des
notes l'effet des plans et puis après
vous l'avez fait en six jours le bouc a
way pendant un an j'ai ici de l'écrire
et je n'arrivais pas j'y arriverai pas
j'y arriverai pas j'y arrivais pas bien
un jour il a fallu vraiment le rendre la
gestion réussie m ouais moi je m'étais
mise quand même parce que j'ai tourné
autour j'ai essayer des trucs des
histoires d'autres histoires des plans
d'autres plans des débits d'eau des bus
ag et se tourner en auto puis bon au
final après il restait plus qu'une
semaine donc là je n'ai fait que la tv
grâce et qui téléphonait tous les jours
au nom même parti croyait même pas avec
j'y croyais et vous vous mettez même
plus la pression non
alors l'histoire c'est l'histoire de
bruno qui est un adolescent de 30 ans
qui était un écrivain
raté agoraphobe la peur de la foule donc
il est bunkerisé chez lui ça fait deux
ans qu'il a pas mis le nez dehors et il
vit au crochet d'une certaine catherine
et puis un jour il a un coup de fil
d'une fille qui s'appelle alice qu'il
sautait à l'époque de sa jeunesse punk
elle est pure tout bourgeoise 1a les
suppositions bourgeoise au fil de
chirurgien ouais ouais et lui fils de
cheminot voilà alors elle l'appelle ça
fait 13 ans qu'il ne se sont pas revus
elle veut absolument le revoir il y va
ils prennent un café place de stalingrad
et lui apprend qu'il est papa d'une
fille de 13 ans et voilà ça lui tombe
dessus
c'est pas ce qui lui arrive et alors
c'est pas fini parce que le soir et me
rentre chez lui et catherine la fille
aux crochets de laquelle il vit le
virent
parce qu'elle en a marre de le voir
glander voilà voilà
et à partir de là donc il est dehors il
faut qu'il trouve chez qui aller
d'autres croient qu'il rencontre la
petite ont-ils la rencontre femmes ans
fatima la rencontre moi un moment avec
un début un milieu et une fin mais
attention au sexe et oussalah maintenant
il ya l'histoire qui évite aux biens
alors au début avec cette petite nan si
donc il sa fille qui a 13 ans qui ne
connaissait pas au début il n'est pas
très content que finalement il dit à ses
copains avec elle et puis comment ça
elle l'assumé
voilà women in viendront karam en commun
certaines rencontres inespérées quand
même pas très réaliste enfin sur ça que
ça arrive d'ailleurs puisque l'on peut
faire des trucs exactement les unit donc
même s'ils passent de l'enfance et
l'adolescence et lui passent de
l'adolescence à l'âge adulte
à ce tarif de rim passage comme ça de
génération en génération
il ya d'autres choses dans le bouquin il
ya c'est que ça reste assez crétin quand
même comme ça ça a l'air pas trop drôle
en fait c'est pas moi c'est d'histoire
brut de décoffrage mais il ya d'autres
choses
et d'abord les compromis qu'il faut
faire dans la vie la réussite sociale
et puis pas de pitié pour les outsider
dans un monde
que vous jugez c'est un petit peu ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure de plus en
plus dur ouais il me semble qu'il ya de
plus en plus d'exclus et que c'est plus
en plus difficile de convenir d'être
dedans quoi et que c'est plus en plus
violent envers ceux qui sont pas dedans
encore à plein plein de niveaux selon
plein de critères pour et que ça devient
chiant que même sur mance a rarement été
aussi dur parce qu'on est vraiment
surveiller partons de s'impliquer
physiquement on est servi dans nos têtes
avec les psy on est surveillé d'heures
de travail d'une façon pas dans tous nos
comportements on est vachement
surveiller et c'est vrai que ça devient
vraiment pénible qu'on voit la maison il
ya de moins en moins d'intérêt tice dans
lesquels subissent et des plantes quoi
aujourd'hui c'est difficile de trouver
des plants bunyan à caraman pam à mettre
offs et même d'une planque est à la
fonction publique ça existera bientôt
plus c'est dur si quand même le niveau
de vie des gens est aussi pris à la
classe moyenne blanche qui existaient
qui existait au moins en moins quoi
quand même qu'ils sacrifiés écrivent
ainsi une bonne planque à mais c'est pas
une solution collective
non il faut écrire c'est le problème
alors vous savez qu'une légende de
virginie despentes un kit et non pas
nancy mais nancy à l'âge de 17 ans est
reparti vivre sur les pentes de la
croix-rousse à lyon
d'où votre pseudo d'ailleurs des pentes
où vivait à l'époque avec des rockers
alternative c'était quoi les béruriers
noirs c'est ça et je veux parler mais
c'était sans comprimer bien et alors
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'elle penserait
la virginie de l'époque si elle vous
voyez moi je serais surprise pour
beaucoup de me voir chez thierry
ardisson à côté de la baronne ce serait
plutôt plus contente que de me voir
j'ai eu de la chance à un gros chante
vous avez de sortie non mais je m'en
suis pas sorti parce que ce que je vis
pas donc les super rigolo tout le temps
pourquoi c'est chiant quand même c'est
vachement effectivement de compromission
c'est vachement de rencontrer des gens
je m'en fous un peu les rencontres et
c'est vachement de prise de tête que je
m'en fous d'avoir
toi la [ __ ] ça fait bientôt les femmes
[Musique]